on peut reprendre que je kiffe j'te
kiffe pas je kiffe pas parce que c'est
pas le moment
encore une fois on l'avait dit la
dernière fois on n'est pas dans la
croyance
on croit pas voir arriver une vague où
on croit pas ne pas la voir arriver on
sait on ne sait pas et quand on ne sait
pas on se tait point barre et je trouve
que c'est très dangereux parce qu'en
plus comme il est il à cette aura parce
que c'est par un savant fou c'est quand
même à certains scientifiques
donc il a une aura de scientifiques et
sa parole porte et sa parole elle porte
auprès d'un certain public qui croit en
lui justement là on est dans la croyance
qui croient en lui
et donc si on croit en lui on va se dire
je peux y aller allons-y on enlève les
masques on ne fait pas les gestes
barrières et puis on prend des risques
la retraite il a raison et je souhaite
de tout mon coeur qu'il ait raison
peut-être qu'il a tort alors s'il a tort
c'est très bon jour et agissez chez vous
on en direct bien entendu le professeur
raoult au coeur d'une nouvelle polémique
la déclaration polémique du professeur à
ou vous qui fait ou qui fait pas et vous
vous dites voilà c'est vrai qu'il a dit
qu' apparemment pour lui donc
coronavirus serait derrière nous battre
à 4 mais c'est pas le seul vous vous
kiffez moi je crie parce que c'est pas
le seul à le dire il dit pas on en
rêvait masque on fait plus attention il
dit je pense par rapport aux as que j'ai
étudié comme courbe je pense que alors
on se parle maintenant
l'épidémie est derrière nous et dis pas
qu'il faut plus faire attention il dit
qu'elle est derrière nous après je
comprends qu'on se con mais moi je suis
je trouve qu'il sait maintenant ce
monsieur alors on l'a adulé un temps
maintenant des qui dit quelque chose on
écrit des conneries mais que cette année
disant scientifiques c'est un mec a eu
des prix encore une fois il n'est pas la
solde des des laboratoires et moi j'ai
envie de le croire parce qu'il donne il
donne de l'espoir après si effectivement
donc dans quinze jours on nous dit qu'on
est confiné on va dire à barrer bas
bravo mais moi j'ai envie de penser
qu'il dit pas ça par hasard et qu'il a
réfléchi avant de le dire